(crowd cheers)
- I have it, look, I have to bring this up
because we're both with the
Christmas tree lighting.
I was most excited.
Like, they were like,
"Will you host the show?"
I was like, sure. Yeah. I love
it. Like, I love Christmas.
I was most excited.
(crowd cheers)
- This is me dancing,
singing every damn word.
I'm not kidding. I wore my sister out
with your song at Thanksgiving.
Like, it came out in October
and I was, I literally
told my, I was like,
please get her on the show.
I was like, I, this is,
"DJ Play a Christmas Song,"
I'm gonna say it, fight me on it,
it's the greatest Christmas song
to come out since "All I
want for Christmas is You."
(crowd cheers)
It's the greatest contemporary
Christmas song to come out.
Like, I, I love it so
much. It makes me so happy.
I'm not, I'm not kidding.
I've sent videos to my friends
like Blake Shelton and Nile.
I've hit them up so much with videos
of me just singing your song.
- Good.
- Yeah. It's so good.
- But you know what, that's what I wanted.
That's the reason I never made
a Christmas album before was
'cause I couldn't find, in my mind,
I couldn't find a way to put myself into,
into a Cher Christmas, you know?
- Really?
- So then I found these, I found my,
a girl I've known since
I, she was four years old,
sent me that song and I
didn't even know it was her.
Sarah Hudson, four years old,
Sarah Hudson, big writer, whatever.
- Yeah.
- So I got that and then all of a sudden
I started to kind of, not, you know,
how your mind is thinking,
but you're not aware of it.
- Yeah.
- But so then I thought about
doing the song with Darlene.
- Oh, I did not know
the backstory on that,
that you originally did.
I didn't know that.
- No.
- I love that you sang the background
and then y'all twisted it and now
she's singing it with you.
- Right?
- No, and I, 'cause I wasn't gonna do it
unless she wanted to sing it with me,
because somehow it just
wouldn't have been right.
But on this, one of the songs on my album,
Darlene Love who sings,
"Baby, Please Come Home"
and everybody knows it,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
- Yeah.
- When I was 17, I did
the background on it.
So when we came together with it,
- I never knew this.
- It was really good.
(crowd cheers)
- I never knew that. I think
I heard you say that on Fallon
and I was like, I never knew that.
I, I think that's incredible.
- No, but how would you
know this like, nameless,
faceless little kid get in the back.
- I know, but it played.
- Cher, could you just step back?
Cher, could you just step back.
Cher, could you just sing a little softer?
- No, but that, oh, that's been my thing.
The whole,
- Right. Yes.
- They're like, you're too loud, blend.
But you're excited. But
I, I have to say this too,
because I think this is incredible
and I don't know any other artist
that has accomplished this,
but this is another number one for you.
And you have number one
spanning seven decades.
(crowd cheers)
- Yeah.
- [Cher] Thank you.
- No one will accomplish that.
- No. Two of us have,
- Who Are you gonna say
a band? Don't say a band.
It's a band.
- It doesn't count.
- Took four of them to be one of me.
- Yay!
(crowd cheers)
- That's my favorite [Inaudible]. Exactly.
- No! The Rolling Stones and me.
- That's incredible.
- Right. And I'm not in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
- Wait, are you serious?
(crowd chatters)
- You know what?
I wouldn't be in it now if
they gave me a million dollars.
- Are you serious?
- I'm not kidding you.
I was about to say something else.
(beep)
Yes, I was about to say I'm not (beep).
- Yeah.
- Right.
- If you ever change your mind-
- I'm never gonna change my mind.
- No, no. If you, okay. I get,
I have things in my career
like that
- I mean,
they can just go and you
know what themselves.
- Yeah, yeah.
(crowd cheers)
- That was brand new information for me.
I'm just saying, if you
ever happen to just get-
- Also, can I just say one other thing?
- Okay.
- I changed music forever with Believe.
(crowd cheers)
- You really did
with that song.
- You know what's so funny?
So let me say one thing.
I feel like DJ Play Me
A Christmas Song
- But let me say one thing.
Let me say one thing.
- Tag, you're it.
- Okay, good.
- No, but I feel
like that's what,
like, how massive and in pop culture
and everything and how it hit
and impacted the pop culture community,
how "Believe" did, I feel
like that's the same vibe
as "DJ Play a Christmas Song."
It's that same vibe. It's,
no one has that sound.
I almost think if
somebody sent me that song
for my Christmas record, I was like,
I don't know if I could pull this off.
I don't know if this is
me. Like, it's so you.
The sound is so Cher.
(crowd cheers)
- It's so incredible.
I love it so much.
So I kind of feel like
it's the same thing.
Like, the same impact. The
same impact that that song,
anyway, I could talk about you forever.
Do you get? I have to ask though,
do you, I heard that you get
nervous, still, on stage?
Do you get nervous?
- Are you kidding me?
- You do?
- Oh, yeah.
- But your Cher.
(crowd laughs)
- Doesn't make
any difference.
- I'm only Kelly and I don't-
- Like, what do you mean?
What are you doing?
You're Cher. Be good.
Be happy, be excited. Don't be scared.
- I know, but you shouldn't
be. You should just walk
around and just say you're welcome.
(crowd laughs)
- No, but
- Especially
around the Hall of Fame.
You're welcome.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- You've inspired so many people
that are in the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame.
This is so I'm not gonna let it go.
- Good.
(crowd cheers)
- Her incredible Christmas
album is called Cher Christmas.
It's out now.
(crowd cheers)
So we talked about it a little.
- Well, wait a minute. What
a great audience you have.
What is this?
- Well, it's you. (laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- I do have great audiences,
but I will say you have an impact.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. Hall of Fame.
So you talked about it a little bit now,
but you took, you know,
you didn't make a
Christmas record till now.
But what I wanna know is, like, you
worked with your boyfriend on it.
So that's, do you like working
with significant others on pro-?
That can, that can go sour?
- Well, I mean, I did it with Son and,
but no, this is, this was
a little bit different
because Alexander and Tyga were in Dubai.
- Yeah.
- Michael Buble was in Argentina.
Cindy was in New York. No,
Cindy was in New Jersey.
Darlene was in New York.
- So, all the people
that were-
- Everybody, they were all
scattered all over the world.
- Yeah.
- Did I leave somebody
out? I probably did.
(Kelly laughs)
- Damn it.
- But, I've never had anybody on an album.
I didn't start out to do this.
- Yeah.
- And I mean, when I, I talked to Cin
and I went, Cin I, I'm gonna,
I think I'm gonna make a Christmas album.
I don't know, but will
you do something on it?
- Oh yeah, yeah, sure. Call me later.
And then I did, I did "What
Christmas Means to Me."
- Yeah.
- And then I thought, "Yeah,
no. No, I need Stevie."
So I called Stevie
and I was like, I really was,
Jenna has a video of me,
'cause I was just,
I just needed him so badly
and I just couldn't bear.
- You are nervous about calling artists
to do things with you?
- Yes.
- This is a, do you, do you
have mirrors in your house?
- Do you, are you aware of
your star and how you shine?
- But you are who you
are. And this is who I am.
- Okay, but I need to let you know
that anyone you call is
gonna be like, "I, yes."
(crowd cheers)
Like, you're unaware.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
But wait a minute.
- Just saying.
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Stevie Wonder is not everybody, okay?
- Neither are you.
- No, well, all right. Well,
that's not important right now.
- Whatever.
- But, so then I get on the
phone, "Stevie, hi, it's me."
And he goes, "Oh, what's up?"
And I said, "I've done your song
and there are parts of it I cannot get.
And I've tried and I've
tried, but they're not me.
They're you. So I need
you to come and do it."
- What a beautiful way to ask.
- Right?
- And so, then, I was still nervous.
Like after he said yes,
I don't think I heard it.
And I just kept selling it.
And then, and then finally
he said at the end he
said, "Cher?, Cher?" What?
"Wait, hold."
And I went, "Yeah?"
And he said, "Do you want
me to play my harmonica?"
And it was like, "Oh, yes. God, thank you.
Thank you so much."
- Exactly! You wanna know why?
'Cause you're (beep) Cher.
- I know.
(crowd cheers)
- Yeah. We're gonna get it through.
What the hell?
- But wait, wait, let me
tell you what happened.
So we hang up the phone and I
go running around my bedroom.
I jump up and down in my bed going,
Stevie Wonder's gonna be on my album.
(crowd cheers)
- It's like, she's completely unaware.
I love that you, I, I still, I love that.
I get excited like that too.
I'm inspired by artists.
I love collaborating. I do that too,
but I just love how
unaware you are of you.
It's pretty great. Yeah.
- In ways I am,
but in other ways
- We just found out.
Yeah.
- But in ways I am, but in
other ways I'm just not.
Because, you know, you,
you are yourself from like,
I've been Cher since I was five,
just people didn't know it, you know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- My mom knew it.
- Yeah.
- But, but people didn't know it.
'cause I was really bizarre.
I mean, I had dyslexia.
I still have it, but I
had it when I was young.
And so my teachers didn't
think I was stupid.
They thought I didn't apply myself
or didn't care or whatever.
- Yeah.
- They had no idea
I was learning everything
through listening to them.
So one time I got an F on my,
on my math test.
So I came home and I was like, not crying,
but I was very, very upset.
And I said, "Mom, I
can't even see numbers.
When I look at 'em, I
don't, I can't see them.
I know that I'm, like, I just can't,
I don't understand them."
And she said, "It's okay, honey.
When you grow up, you're gonna have
someone to do math for you."
(crowd cheers)
- I love your mother.
- No. Can I tell you this?
- I'm so thankful that
you're open about that
because I actually found that out.
And my daughter's dyslexic.
And like, I, I went home last night
and we have dance parties
all the time at our house
and the dance party we have now.
Like, my kids know your song so well.
"DJ, Play a Christmas Song,"
that's all we've been
doing in our living room.
And anyway, I said, "Hey, you know,"
'cause she just found out she has
to have tutoring again or whatever.
And she was very upset about it.
And so anyway, when I told her, I said,
"Hey, you know what?
The girl who sings a
song we've been dancing
to almost every night. I
was like, she's dyslexic.
I was like, and she's, she's better than
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame."
(crowd cheers)
And I'm telling you, I'm telling you,
it made her feel so powerful that,
because I was like, you don't see it
as a superpower, but it is.
You just see things
differently. That's all.
Most people see it one way.
You see it differently.
But having people like you
who are so massively popular
and people love you and adore
you, and you're so successful
and you know, you have this amazing life,
having kids that have
that to look up to is
so cool that you're open about it.
(crowd cheers)
Because I'm not dyslexic.
So she gets very, you
know, very sad about it.
- No, it's, it's really difficult
because you feel that you, well,
you just feel that you're stupid.
And, and that's,
- That's right, yeah.
- And there was no name
for it when I was little.
- There was just nothing,
you know? There was nothing.
- Makes it even harder.
- But the thing I couldn't do
that I learned how to do, Sonny helped me.
I couldn't read because in those days,
you had to read in every class.
You had to read so many chapters.
I just couldn't do it.
- Well, even with math,
the problem is usually it's in word form,
like, hey, do da da da and
that would confuse her.
- Yeah, it's confusing as
hell, all those things.
And then, and then Sonny gave me,
when he and I got together,
'cause I said, you know, I wanna read,
but, and I can read, but I just
can't do it quickly at all.
- Um-hm.
- Except I can memorize a
script at after one time.
So, go figure.
- Yeah.
- But, so he gave me a book
called "The Saracen Blade."
And I read it and I was
like, "This is heaven.
This is just heaven."
- When you find a book
that you really love.
- And then I just started
reading everything.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
he and I got in a fight
because I was reading
Mario Puzo, you know,
"The Godfather," in the bathroom.
"Cher, go to bed."
"I will be there in a minute."
(crowd laughs)
- I was reading it.
- This is a good part.
- Right.
- Yeah. Oh, I love books like that.
When you get in, when you,
- Yeah.
- Ugh.
So do you think you're gonna act again?
Like do any, because I, we
love you acting, as well.
(crowd cheers)
- We love you acting.
- Well, there's two scripts that
I'm doing
(Kelly gasps)
or I don't know that I'm doing,
but I'm thinking about doing 'em.
- You should think more about it.
- And they keep saying,
"Mamma Mia 3, Mamma Mia 3."
- Oh my god, I love it. Yes.
(crowd cheers)
I love that. I loved when
I saw you in that one,
I was like, wait, what?
This is like, it was
Meryl and Cher colliding.
It was, it was awesome for me
because I'm a huge fan of both.
Well, I love you so much
and I know that you are working
your tail off with promo right now.
(crowd cheers)
- So, thank you
for stopping by.
I'm so happy I'm here. This
is a blessing. I'm such a fan.
I love you so much. Everybody
give it up for Cher.
(crowd cheers)
Her album is called Cher
Christmas. It's out now.
Now you've gotta go check it out.